Speaker 1: Let's talk a little bit about
Republican reactions to failed former President
Donald Trump having this white supremacist dinner
with Nick Fuentes and Kanye West and others at Mar
a Lago. Mike Pence does something, which is it's
almost difficult to do in a sense. Mike Pence will
come around and make a statement, supposedly
based on principle and whatever. And it's like
the blandest, most milquetoast, most meaningless
statement he could possibly make that just falls
so embarrassingly and humiliatingly short of what
people should be saying. So as an example of the
type of reaction that I would like to see more
from Republicans, just figure just a find. Rather,
the recent statement from Mitt Romney, which
I don't have here available but is widely
available up on. Just completely unequivocal,
unquestioning condemnation of this dinner that
Donald Trump had. Mike Pence, on the other hand,
wants Donald Trump to apologize for the dinner
with the anti-Semite apology. I think he should
apologize. The Associated Press has an article
about it. We have the clip. Let's take a look
at it. Here is Mike Pence on News Nation and
he wants an apology and all the way, by the
way. Notice there is a butt here as well.
Speaker 3: President Trump was wrong to give
of a white nationalist, an anti-Semite and a
Holocaust denier a seat at the table. And
I think he should apologize for it. Wow.
Speaker 1: You should really apologize
for that. That was the wrong thing to do.
Speaker 3: You should denounce those individuals
and their hateful rhetoric without qualification.
With that being said, as I point out in the book.
Speaker 1: With that being said, you know,
there's other stuff I need to mention here.
Speaker 3: As well. I,
I don't believe Donald Trump is an anti-Semite.
I don't believe he's a racist or a bigot. I would
not have been his vice president if he was.
Speaker 1: That's a lie. Now that that that's
that's where it starts to get unbelievable. You
wouldn't have been his vice president. Come on,
Mike. We don't believe that you were thirsty
for power in the spotlight. A guy comes to you
who's the nominee, and he says, I want
you to be my running mate. And you go,
I don't know. I mean, you're you're kind
of a little bit racist. I can I'm not
going to do it. Nobody believes that.
Speaker 3: And, you know, people often
forget the the president's daughter converted to
Judaism. The other son in law is a devout Jew.
His grandchildren, he's a Jew.
Speaker 1: So, listen,
we've talked about this before. It's less with
Trump about. I've also made some of the same
observations that Mike Pence is making here.
Jared Kushner, his son in law, is Jewish. His
own daughter converted to Judaism. His grandkids,
some of his grandkids are now Jewish. With Trump,
it's not about the type of anti-Semitism that
would have him denounce his own daughter. It's
about similar to Trump with his preconceived
notions about people from certain countries,
or same with Trump when it comes to his views on
LGBTQ individuals. It's not the type of virulent
phobia or isms that some of my former guests on
the show have exhibited. But it is more of like
a low grade casual. Here is my sort of beliefs
about these people, and he tolerates them and
whatever the case may be, but he's not so against
the racism and xenophobia and whatever, that he
will unilaterally denounce it from his movement
and reject individuals who do harbor those views.
That's the type of view and type of person that
Donald Trump is and views that he holds. Now,
as far as Mike Pence here. Okay. This is both
too little and too late when it comes to Mike
Pence. And in fact, it's quite pathetic.
And what I mean about that is the following.
If these right wing Republicans like Pence wanted
us to really believe that they are completely
against the type of views espoused by Fuentes
and Kanye West. And I don't even remember. Was
Milo Yiannopoulos part of that dinner? I don't
know. I don't remember exactly who was there.
It would be more powerful if they denounce
the people within their own parties that had
these views, because there's members of the
Republican Party who are elected officials
in the House of Representatives and to some
degree even in the Senate who have a variety
of these views. And there they are, silent. And
so it's easy to call out Nick Fuentes or Kanye
West and people who are being not universally,
but but at least by some political movements,
denounced. It's easy to do that. Call out the
elected officials in your party. This is too
little, too late for Mike Pence. And now I
want to talk about Mitch McConnell as well.